and now I will tell us about matrix
multiplication hi thanks for coming
thanks for you know I think me so I
would like to tell you something about
boolean matrix multiplication and about
proving some other bounds for it and
actually what we will pouffy will prove
some rubber bands for some common at all
type of algorithms so I will try to
explain you what I mean
and this is so joint work with my
student the bharata das and mike sucks
programmers so let me just remind you
what boolean matrix multiplication is
because we would be on the same page
so by boolean of course I mean that the
values are just 0 1 and then still the
question is actually over which field so
it's actually not over field it's
actually over this bull and Semmering so
it's basically a mess on doors so it's a
so you get two matrices which has your
one matrices and you know each each
entry CIJ is basically this you get
working on leash on the row here and on
the particular column here and basically
you are taking instead of taking
multiplication you are taking and and
then you are taking or over all these so
this is a what we mean by boolean matrix
multiplication and we would like to
understand it a little bit better so let
me just actually just quick remark it
actually basically corresponds or it's
closely related to to designing
connectivity in say tripartite graphs or
in general like actually in directed
graphs of arbitrary size but if you look
on the this tripartite graphs imagine
that the edges section just going from
left to right and you have three parts
ABCD of say the same size and you are
just trying to figure out which vertices
on the left are connected to which word
this is on the right so if you actually
described basically the connections over
here by incidence matrix and connections
over here also by incidence matrix then
the product of the two matrices PQ is
exactly
gives you the connections from left to
right and that's exactly the boolean
matrix multiplication product so that's
actually what is it about and people are
interested in this because it actually
captures a very natural problem people
care about and that's actually
connectivity in in in directed graphs so
what can we say about algorithms for for
this program so of course the ninth
algorithm takes n cubed time but there
is much faster way and that's actually
you know starting this Justins algorithm
all the way actually to like recent work
of Lego we do have an algorithm which
actually works for this very fast
because you can actually just use the
usual integer multiplication or
multiplication of matrices over heels
and basically you mean depends what kind
of operations you get ok matrix
multiplication you can just work modulo
prime larger than n 0 o P
okay so oh I see was very very concerned
about like bit sign section okay so so
this could be the end of us the story
but but actually people are I mean
people are not happy about these
algorithms for various reasons and there
is actually a long line of work actually
basically could call it sharing logs but
the goal is actually to design some
other algorithms for this program for
brain matrix multiplication which would
be kind of more natural and like easier
to grasp and understand so basically
there is a result from already 70s which
kind of shakes off from this table upper
bound work square and that's partially
based on like what level of parallelism
partially on some other ideas and that
was only like a few years back it was
actually improved by like extra 0.125
Flocka actually and then there is a
improvement by by extra wall basically
and an outer lock and so there is a this
kind of indicates that people are
actually interested still in other
algorithms for boolean matrix
multiplication besides actually the ones
which are implied by fast matrix
multiplication so the question is
actually what our limits of these
algorithms you know these algorithms are
not easy
well actually this one is a fairly
simple but these are not actually easy
at all and they actually some of them
actually are quite complicated and rest
on launch of the results so what's the
limit of these techniques can we
actually go substantially far beyond
this and cube by comment of algorithms
so what is a combinatorial great so what
do I mean by that
so actually part of the this actually
endeavor is to somehow come up with
reasonable definition or would be and so
like the easy definition would be
welcome until it's anything what's known
based on fast matrix multiplication so
that would be kind of like the obvious
first definition but that's not what we
would like to actually have so so rather
actually you would like to say what the
community means although it
is actually hard to define so we don't
quite actually have a good definition
for that except that somehow the natural
natural way what we would like to say is
that this algorithm should kind of
collect information about the product in
some model connotation in some sense so
there should be in some sense a witness
for the fact that you know the resulting
matrix is something what it is so it
seems that there should be some kind of
proof system and the common at all
always the way people actually sing
about them basically are kind of trying
to prove that the matrix looks way it
tastes so it's time to derive some some
basically information about the entries
of the matrix in some incremental
monotone fashion so that's what we
actually would like to have as a
competitor definite comment has a
definition of comment or algorithms
although we don't actually we don't
quite manage to capture everything so so
this is what what we mean by common
algorithm or somehow the direction we
would like to go so my community
algorithms are what they said I mean
because they actually are are
interesting ins alright actually people
usually are much better in implementing
Common App algorithms than like fast
matrix multiplication but moreover it
would actually give you more insight
into this program of actually
multiplying matrices and it could also
give you actually inside for multiplying
matrices over other settings for example
like main path Semmering which is like
which completes all pairs shortest paths
or it segments to competing all pairs
shortest paths in a graph and the best
algorithm is actually algorithm by Ryan
which actually does like n cubed over 2
to the Big O of square of organa
so that's you know so we get again we
get actually much better for much better
algorithm for this and cubed sorry for
this all pairs shortest path them than
the cumulative algorithms get for blue
matrix multiplication but still just
kind of don't get even like truly sub
cubic algorithm so so it's actually a
reasonable question to understand these
Commendatore algorithms whatever are
they so so the first one actually to try
to actually capture what what the
program is or what would could be a
model for kominato algorithms was
actually unguent sin 76 and she actually
defined the following the following
model which I will try to describe and
we kind of actually extend this model in
various ways so so she basically takes a
paradigm that basically you know I have
this matrix P and Q and I have this I'm
trying to compute its resulting matrix
and what is the resulting matrix so the
resulting matrix basically how can you
get it well you take a critical role
from here and that row actually selects
some of the some of the rows in in in
this next matrix Q in the second Matrix
in particular wherever you have one and
that means actually you select these
rows and then what you do you basically
do bitwise or of these rows and that
gives you this rule so or you can call
it Union so you basically you think of
these as characters like vectors of
course of a set and you basically take a
union of these three sets and you do it
for each of the rows and now the
question I'm going to ask is actually
how many of these rows do you need to
actually compute sorry how many of these
unions actually you need if you are
making them kind of binary so say I
allow you only binary binary unions that
how many you will actually need so in
particle you can sing over a model that
actually for given matrix P and Q it
actually gives you some some some
prescription how we chose to actually
take Union off and you take various
unions of various rows you get some
intermediate results and make sure you
you actually should get all all
different rows which you need to
assemble your resulting matrix R so so
basically get some kind of circuit of
unions so it's kind of basically like a
binary circuit in the sense that it has
binary fanon and
operations are unions what is floating
to these is actually roles and what
about is the input the input are arrows
of the original matrix Q of the of the
right matrix q and that's actually
floating through this circuit and the
question is how big this circuit should
be so that corresponds basically - how
many unions you have to take to actually
compute this resulting matrix and
angular actually gives an answer and she
shows that actually you know it's a like
N squared over log n is a lower bound
and it turns out that this is actually
tight so you just need actually an
squared over log and unions in let me
just emphasize so this is not a circuit
which would actually work for arbitrary
matrix p 8q this circuit actually
depends on matrix P and Q so so given
given I give you P and Q just designed
optimum a what is the complexity of your
circuit computing this eight times X so
nature scrubs of them Evans was over
there yeah so the bonus matrix
notification is intervals all right and
so that would imply any cube
login upper bound from model time I'm
saying there's really you're doing
something like maybe login these guys so
these guys are actually like and bits
long because right so that actually
gives you this extra walk saving ice
that's what you are describing is
basically how to get a slogan something
similar so right so that's that's one
way I have to say this there is this and
cubed over log squared s ik like one of
the savings comes from what you
basically are this correct so so this is
actually I'm going smaller and well if
you would translate it translate it into
actually you know if you just take a
table implementation of this of this and
you would try to basically you would
like to actually do the calculation
using this scheme then how much would it
cost you well you have these vectors of
n bits so so you are taking Union so if
you just apply the triple Albertan it's
going to cost you like time and cubed
over again to actually evaluate such
such a witness so if I give you the
witness and you want to evaluate if you
want to verify the time you're treating
you then you are going to basically
spend like n cube log n time on
emulating is that's what it seems but
actually it's not quite true so so let
me actually just remind you actually I
didn't say say it but angular it's
actually a lot about this obtained just
by simple counting argument so if you
just do sample counting and you count
how many such circuits you have and how
many different vertices matrices are
there then you just immediately get like
other no matrix is going to actually
require an N square over log n log n
guys but if you take R and Omega
q then what happens is that actually if
you look on this circuit then once you
actually take a few unions actually will
get like all bunnies on one vectors
because like blood matrix num1 matrix
multiplication actually once you take
union of or log n rows if the matrices
are random if the matrix q is random
then you basically have like a vector of
all ones so so then what you what
happens is that actually if you look on
the circuit as such then there is going
to be on may evolve like n log n this
thing unions you can actually take
because everything else is kind of like
civilized and there is nothing else to
do so if you were really actually tried
if you would take a row matrices P and Q
and try to actually avoid overlay them
already sweetness then you can actually
do it much faster because if you will be
clever and you will notice that you know
you already got like all of our vector
then and you you don't have to do
anything actually so so this doesn't
quite prove that it should actually be
complicated to compute boolean matrix
multiplication by some common natural
means and so so what is our models are
how we are trying to actually fix this
issue is this or you know model so we
try to actually change the cost function
you actually charge for for various
actually for various of these operations
so so instead of actually completely
taking cost of each operation to be like
m because its ambit vector what we are
going to charge other so we are going to
sing well maybe you actually use parse a
presentation for this for these vectors
so so what we are going to charge you we
are just going to charge you basically
the minimal of the kind of the Hamming
weight of the small of the two vectors
which actually come into the action so
so that basically corresponds to like
having like sparse vector representation
and what else actually so if actually if
there are two units which actually give
the same result or or I traded the two
and
do the basically the developers which
actually entered that union and if these
two actually are the same then we are
just going to charge for it once because
you can actually easily recognize say by
fingerprinting that you are actually
taking union of the two same things so
we are not going to charge your game and
if you do if we were to do this for the
random matrices then actually the cost
is going to be just an square login and
here we go we get the common logarithm
so it would be very easy way to get the
Commendatore algorithm just using
actually this fix and so the question is
actually what's the cost in this model
and so known instances the cost would be
and square law again and but it turns
out that actually luckily for us
actually it's not
luckily for us or depends so if you want
to farm on an upper bound so it turns
out that actually even in this model
actually the boolean matrix
multiplication still cost like n cubed
at least n cubed over 2 to the square of
log n yeah although this bound actually
reminds you this is result I think
actually this 2/3 order square root of
log and actually comes for different
reasons but it's the same function so
that's actually first result so that's
actually for different problem and it's
not in this moment right not superb um
is for this all pairs shortest paths and
it's actually not in this moment I
wouldn't actually call it also combat at
all
so okay so but this is actually a very
simplistic model and it actually is not
even capable of actually implementing
many of these common mental algorithms
which which I've actually shown use also
all these algorithms which actually
shave these slots actually none of them
is actually well we can actually shape
like single log actually in that model
but we cannot shape like two logs so so
to actually try this also our goal is
actually to capture all these companies
or algorithms but so far we succeeded
basically with capturing only the first
ones on the shaving these two ops and so
this would be our next model so if you
look on this comment algorithms how do
they actually usually operate so so what
they do is they take this matrix Q or P
and they break it into pieces and then
they actually operate on these pieces
and as before they basically do these
unions of small pieces and you know
based on actually how these pieces look
like they may do they take may take it
this unions or that unions
and eventually like when by by the end
of the day somehow what I do is they
actually assemble all this information
together and here we go so so an actual
natural like extension of the model I I
described would be the following model
which will actually allow you to break
this these vectors into pieces do union
of those small pieces and then then
assemble stuff back so over here I would
start with row and I would miss the rows
of Q I could actually break break that
into continuous pieces you know I could
send one piece here and another piece
elsewhere and then I could actually
concatenate these pieces back so so I
would do that say at the end and in
between I would be taking Union of
whatever pieces I have so that's kind of
more general model and how would I
charge you actually for these operations
so it seems meaningful to actually
charge you know we want to charge for
proving other bands you want to
a small cost as possible for the lotto
bound to be meaningful and from
algorithmic perspective you don't want
to be actually more expensive than what
you could charge in any other algorithm
so so if you chart actually a constant
for breaking a row into continuous
pieces constant for concatenating pieces
that's actually algorithmically
reasonable and for taking Union of
pieces we will still actually basically
charge just the minimum number of fonts
and we will charge again like if there
are two things which actually look the
same then we actually are going to
charge charge only months for them so so
that's that's the that's the next model
where we can actually pull our bounds if
actually if the operations are actually
like ordered so so first we actually can
be able to break the rows into pieces
then we are taking union of the pieces
under me we can concatenate you're only
charging once if two things look the
same is that as vectors vectors if they
are even if they are talking about
different elements if they actually are
about the same binary vectors then we
actually charged just four months which
again it's actually from algorithmic
perspective that's actually you able
seem reasonable to things to do because
you can easily model it by always so so
in this model actually what we can show
is you can show that well ideally we
would like to have an algorithm ASEAN's
in like quadratic time so if we just
like order and squared algorithm which
would correspond to having matrix
multiplication in quadratic time so what
we can show is that in this model at
least it's not possible so so we get
like super quadratic clutter bound in
particle n to the 2 + 1 / search again
divided by this 2 to the order of log n
a lot of bound on the cost of actually
doing boolean matrix multiplication in
in this in this model and this model is
actually as I as I said before it's
actually good in the sense that
it at least disabled to capture the
first of the shaming lock algorithms
algorithms is sometimes called for
Russians algorithm interaction actually
so then the next step would be how to
generalize this model and that's
actually tricky because if you try to
generalize the model well you have to
define and you have to decide what the
operations are going to be you have to
define what decide what actually the
charging scheme will be so how much you
are going to pay for various operations
and you know if you actually charge too
little and then the lower bounds each
you may get will be trivial because just
it will be possible very easily actually
to to actually it just will be possible
to actually calculate and very small and
say in an N squared it will be possible
to actually calculate product of any two
matrices so you have to be somehow
careful you have to strike the right
balance to actually get some meaningful
result and so far we didn't actually
quite managed to do that and the obvious
generalization will be just to allow
actually an arbitrary interleaving of
these operations of actually breaking
into pieces and taking unions and then
maybe breaking it again and concatenated
various pieces so so basically the
questions which which we actually leave
and which we are hoping to summon or we
will be able to actually kind of flow up
upon is what what's the right mix of the
operation what's the right basically the
right model for kominato algorithms so
and so that means what should be the mix
of the patient's which should be the
cost function
so so I have a few minutes so let me
just tell you actually how we prove this
result so originally you saw that it's
going to be piece of cake to actually
prove the slobber bounds but it turns
out it's actually not that easy although
the model is like very restricted as you
can see then it's not it's by no means
stable I would say to put these rubber
bands and or at least we didn't finance
0-2 and so what we you see we actually
used these graphs which which have
amazing properties so let me actually
just tell you tell you about these
because I think they should be like used
more often and I know that they are use
in some contexts but this is just really
amazing graphs you wouldn't believe that
they exist so so this I call this I
refer to as Lucius Emily graphs from 78
and these are bit bipartite graphs which
are basically like dense they have
almost like n square edges but at the
same time they look very sparse in what
sense well in the sense that you can
actually you can actually cover all the
edges by n over 3 so basically near a
number of these joint induced matchings
and each of the matching is of size like
n over 2 3 or square of Logan's so it's
almost linear sized matchings linear
number of them and they are induced that
means that if you actually take take
part over here over here then the only
edges you will see is actually the edges
of the matching so this linear number of
edges so there should be like quadratic
number of actually match it there is
like quadratic number of possible edges
between these 3 vertices and these 3
vertices but you will see only in a
linear number of them so they kind of
look locally very sparse
although they are like globally they are
extremely dense so so it sounds almost
impossible that they exist but they do
actually
so so how do we use them so out of these
we actually build a tripartite graph and
we build it in the following way so we
basically put here
on the left side we put at this side a
on the right side they put this side see
and in the middle we actually we
actually put a new new set B riches
subsides as a client and an oversea and
each of these vertices represents one of
the one of the matching sanction so then
we actually connect then we connect for
for each each matching edge sorry each
matching vertex we actually connect to
the web this is a check ship which
actually take part in dot mention so if
we do this then what you actually obtain
well you obtain a very dense graph so we
basically again you get almost almost
pathetic number of edges in those whole
graph but it is the property that there
is actually there is actually there is
actually going to be this many pairs of
vertices so again almost quadratic
number of vertices which are connected
uniquely by a unique path so that means
for example these guys the only path
between them is actually why are this
matching and there is no other path
between them and you will have lot of
these pairs which again sounds
contributed counter intuitively because
you have actually done the graph so you
should you should expect that basically
you know typically there is between
almost any pair of points you should
like expect like a linear number of
paths in between about it's actually
this is like very very specific graph so
we actually use these graphs we actually
randomized the right part to kind of
make it distinct and you actually use
them to prove the to prove them rubber
band so let me conclude so so we have
open programs and the kind of most most
interesting is actually what's the right
model for coming out all written or what
would be the right proof system actually
for for these things
of course the another really nice
question and I would love to actually
see some progress on actually getting
new Commendatore logarithms basically
breaking this this
NQ plateau band so say getting like
truly sub cubic home here two algorithms
so I think
it's a really actually interesting
research question just to speed up Bora
matrix multiplication by other means
than just by fast matrix multiplication
and of course what would be a lot of
bounds for the monomial
you design so that's
[Applause]
was very clear
[Applause]